hello glad you've joined us for this
live webinar better answers faster Drive
instrument innovation with 95% QE and
computational imaging I'm Julie O'Rourke
of lab routes and I'll be moderating
this session today's educational web
seminar is presented by lab routes the
leading scientific social networking
website and provider or virtual events
and webinars advancing scientific
collaboration and learning it's brought
to you by photo metrics founded in 1978
photometric is an established industry
leader in designing award-winning
high-performance scientific Auto metrics
maintains its leadership role with the
release of prime the first and only s
CMOS camera to provide built-in
computational intelligence or image
restoration and more recently the
prime95 be the first scientific CMOS
camera to offer 95% quantum efficiency
photo metrics also offers comprehensive
OAM support to learn more visit photo
metrics comm let's get started you can
pose questions to the speaker during the
presentation while they're fresh in your
mind to do so simply type them into drop
down box located on the far left of your
screen labeled ask a question and click
on the send button questions will be
answered after the presentation to
enlarge the slide window click on the
arrows at the top right hand corner of
the presentation window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support tab found at the top right
of the presentation window or for your
problem by typing it into the answer a
question box located on the far left of
your screen this is an educational
webinar and thus offers free continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits have
located at the top right of the
presentation window
and follow the process of obtaining her
credits I now presented a speaker Steve
Smith PhD Oh II am marketing manager and
photo metrics you've completed yes in
biological sciences and a PhD in
biomedical sciences Colorado State
University his research in dr. Deborah
races lab focused on membrane events
during cellular signaling using
biochemical and optical methods
professionally Steve's career has
focused on microscopy and imaging
spanning areas from laser scanning
confocal and multiphoton techniques to
power based systems at photo metrics
Steve uses his decade of imaging
experience held om collaborators choose
the right camera for their application
on price performance spectrum these
Smith will now begin his presentation
thank you Judy thank you for the kind
introduction and thank you to lab roots
for the great platform here with which
to present some some cool cool cool
information
satting on many elaborate seminars so
it's fun to be be presenting one so
greetings to to all thank you for
joining us from from it sitting in
Tucson Arizona and the grips of are
above Tucson winter here so we also are
our headquarters is in Tucson and we
manufacture in Surrey British Columbia
just outside Vancouver photometric s--
is a company that's that's been around
this is our 40 year anniversary this
year and we've been a tech leader in the
imaging industry for those four years
and we're proud of a lot of technical
firsts today's seminar is about driving
instrument innovation and getting to
better answers faster and innovation has
been part of the photometric DNA since
since the creation of the company in
1978 when we started as an astronomy
company with with with CCDs we got well
you know some of the highlights of our
technological first here include back
thinning OSI CDs in 1986 EMC CDs and in
2001 and then more recently some of the
we'll cover today is in the vacuum in
CMOS technology that we released about
in 2016 so over those 40 years we've
seen camera technology Conway so from
the CC DS above the where the company
was founded around on to EMC CDs for
really low light packaging and now on to
to CMOS cameras the imaging world has
taken a lot that's how to rapid
progression through these especially in
the last few years we've really seen the
explosion of CMOS technology up through
2010 see CDs were where the were
dominating the landscape in in all
industries see see these are a great
imaging technology they're they're very
very good at what they do but they sort
of force you into a two menu where if
you look at the three important
parameters of imaging being resolution
sensitivity and speed a CCD camera can
really be excellent at sort of any two
of those so if you have some sensitive
camera it's with high resolution it's
not going to be fast and if you need to
go fast
ambu head up the sensitive camera it's
not going to have many pixels you're
going to have that's why we had the 128
and the 512 by 512 sort of arrays back
in the day for for going fast so you
sort of find the lid with on with two
parameters you were interested in for
for creating your imaging system this
was pretty good though this this carried
the scientific industry for a lot of
years and was really nice for for fixed
log4 for a lot of lifestyle work and
then Along Came CMOS we stay around here
we say CMOS has eaten the world and you
can see the rise of CMOS you know since
its introduction this is a graphical
death of the consumer market so the
scientific market is about 1 1 to 2
years behind this you can see the rapid
adoption and proliferation of CMOS
cameras over the last few years why why
CMOS so compelling it is
it really gave you a nice blend of all
these so CMOS has become so popular has
become a staple in the scientific and
consumer world because it really gives
you a nice blend there big chips did get
the resolution there their large sensors
they're extremely fast and they've come
a long way in the noise performance the
sensitivity was was slightly improved in
the early going we'll get back to that
in a bit
this is an illustration we use this line
called an agro light slide that's a
quantitative non leachable fluorescent
standard for a lot of our measurements
and head-to-head comparisons of cameras
so shows even an older ccd camera versus
a more modern CMOS camera this is
actually a generation or two old CMOS
camera but nonetheless you see the the
vast improvement that you get out of the
lower green noise and an improved
efficiency in the CMOS world so this is
this is why CMOS hasn't in the world
that sensitivity bit high minute I
mentioned has has come a long way very
rapidly as well so we've seen that Kili
come up in the CMOS world on the CMOS
cameras from from 55 to 72 as they
remove a transistor and that was a in
the pixel design so that was a big
advance and in insensitivity they went
to a gapless micro lens design that got
another 10% boost in QE says you'll see
existing CMOS technology and if you've
been following the camera world camera
companies tout this QE as a Coryell to
Cornerstone parameter of the Cameron of
the imaging performance of a system so
so see this is kind of reasoning behind
some of these jumps so the gapless micro
lens has got you another 10% and you see
that we're really stretching that
sensitivity piece where we're now you
know we have the high resolution we have
the high speed sensors and now we're
pushing that sensitivity the gold
standard and sensitivity has always been
EMCC eats the when you really need to
dig down in the dirt and get down into
the low low signal levels 95 % QE that's
been a staple in the a.m CCD cameras is
still a sort of the bulb has been the
gold standard I'll try to
that is that is now on that has now gone
to back will needed CMOS so driving is
for innovation our company is focused
into two worlds we're focused as a
scientific group and we serve the
research community through that and
we're we're extremely focused as an OEM
organization working with partners and
in creating and supplying a camera as a
component to instruments that helps
drive your instruments to be better and
that's the focus of today's talk is sort
of the the instrumentation and the OEM
side of our business
so with this 95 % QE sensor has where's
what I mean by where is the
instrumentation come in so the CMOS
sensors we now have back illuminated
CMOS sensors that allow that give you so
the back illumination I should say so
you basically turn the sensor around
upside out it's illuminated to the
backside in the old sensors you have to
steer the light back to the
light-sensitive surface and so this is
where you you encounter some trouble
with the electronics that are part of
the the sensor and why the micro lenses
improved that you can see in the image
here the micro lens is helping to steer
the light back to the light reactive
surface well turning the sensor around
to a back illuminated architecture
solves that problem so you get the the
light directly interfacing with the
light reactor the light-sensitive
surface here and and so you get you know
how to percent fill factor you don't
have to worry about this but angular
dependence on the light coming in and
the micro lenses to steer it and you get
this extremely high a 95 percent quantum
efficiency so this is what we now have
we now have EMC CB level sensitivity
with back illuminated CMOS so you get
all the benefits of CMOS the big sensors
and speed now with that sensitivity
piece having caught up and having having
equal its performance so our mantra and
the OEM side of our business has been to
help our partners provide better
is faster and this gave me a chance to
to think about it all my favorite
Seinfeld references here from from Cosmo
Kramer talking about a horse for a
course and designing something that's
good at something and it's our goal is
to is to collaborate with our OEM
partners to create the camera that has
just the right balance of price and
performance to help your instruments be
better to get better answers faster what
this means for us is that you know it
may be in low light applications that
are our arms working and they may need
that extreme sensitivity to dig down in
the dirt in low-level fluorescence they
may need to go fast and may have an
application where speed is is of the
essence they may be looking at things
where a large field of view is what it
takes to help them win their market and
better their instrumentation we have a
long history in long stair applications
we've done a lot of om business over the
years and what we call a long stair
imaging and another important part we'll
talk a lot about today is in the
computational applications of this and
then what we call computational imaging
and the we'll save that for a bit but
that is really in the beginning to those
better answers faster so our first such
horse for course our first camera too to
mention as far as creating that platform
that will make make instruments better
is the prime95 B it is a it's the first
back eliminated scientific CMOS camera
released to the market it's named the 95
B because of its 95 percent quantum
efficiency across the bulk of the
visible spectrum here so this is the QE
profile of the camera and you can see
that across the the visible range there
in the in the you know 500 to the 400 to
700 but particularly in the 5 to about
650 range you're well above 90% QE which
is in the bulk of the visible so
excellent in the greens excellent
it's the Reds and and this is where you
know that the quantum efficiency just to
back up I probably should have should we
get asked a lot e of quantum efficiency
is simply the efficiency of the sensor
in converting photon energy to electrons
so if you have a hundred elect 100
photons excuse me striking the
photoreactive surface and 95 are turned
to electrons that's your 95% efficiency
to the sensor so you can see where this
is important as it's climbed from the
50s to the 70s to the 80s to 95 this is
your raw horse power in your imaging
application and this is then so this
this is why we're so proud of this 95 %
QE bit the backside CMOS really is an
e/m CCD replacement so this is a head
head imaging example with the the
prime95 backside illuminated CMOS versus
the an e/m CCD camera and you can see
really really equivalent performance but
but also when you factor in that the the
prime psi is a 1200 by 1200 array as
opposed to a 512 by 512 you get the
additional benefit of the the larger
field of view as well so a couple images
here by way of example to show you that
the prime95 really does equal the other
performance of the of the e/m CCD
cameras here is versus a 1 km CCD and
against the competitive landscape of
CMOS right now so the the previous high
watermark as far as QE and CMOS was 82%
so we looked at the exact same sample on
the exact same microscope with the two
camera set up there just flipped a lot
the light to the left port then to the
right and you can see the advantage of
that that raw horsepower and imaging and
then the camera gives you so you have a
30 millisecond exposure looking at this
this wrap neuron and you can see the
performance that you can expect with
these high QE care ones glamour shot
here this is the camera this is what it
what it looks like is in the front
female we also have
my own version available for for larger
field of view it's got air and water
cooling options it's a very nice robust
camera also should mention that would
like to mention that we we use a gem to
four-lane PCIe interface so our cameras
speak essentially directly to
motherboard they use a non proprietary
PCIe card
we don't use a frame grabber we've heard
for many om partners that the frame
grabber piece introduces an extra layer
of drivers and and sometimes
communication issues to work through so
we've gone around the frame grabber we
speak directly to the motherboard via
PCIe bus and can transfer data extremely
fast and we also use USB 3 interfaces
for for those if that's preferred for
our way in partnership the following the
95b we released another 95 % QE sensor
called our camera called the prime vsi
it's another back-illuminated scientific
CMOS but this time with six and a half
micron pixels i skipped through it by
the the prime95 b is an 11 micron pixels
so it's a bigger pixel show you the
importance of that and a second here but
six half micron pixels and an electron
and change 1.1 electrons read noise so
it's a dynamic camera so same story
excuse me same story here the back
illuminated CMOS 95% QE
but here this time of the smaller pixel
prize so the six and a half by six 1/2
micron pixel has been extremely popular
pixel size in the scientific imaging
world because of this the idea of
spatially sampling your ears your sample
by achieving Nyquist imaging criteria so
Nyquist states that you'd like to have
two units of of resolution for every to
two sampling units for every one unit of
resolution so you'd like to have two
pixels for every one resolvable unit and
so you can see the the prime95 p with
its 11 micron pixels maps very well to a
high mag objective like 100 X 150 X the
60 x subject
it was extremely widely used in the
biomedical sciences and so the private
BSI with the success micron pixels is a
really nice nice addition to the back
psi 95 % QE lineup because of that that
that matched to the 60 x objective
showing the QE curve here of the of the
prime95 be against the 72% and 82%
cameras it's a big advantage there but
maybe more interesting to look at on a
real sample so we looked at a couple of
a stem sample with with all of our
cameras and then put a line across it
and with aligned thoughts you see the
the intensities here across the cameras
the prime BSI is up above as expected
maybe the interesting bit of data on
this slide is that as we've tested this
over and over the the 72% version of
CMOS and the 82% version performed
pretty similarly so we don't get the
expected benefit from 82% you know it's
a we believe it's a you know different
micro lens design here with the gapless
micro lenses and so you know see quite
as much advantage to the 82% as we might
have expected but you sure see that 95%
perform perform nicely against the ginko
sample there that's another illustration
of that so the prime BSI with the 95 %
QE against the 82% generation of current
CMOS cameras the prime psi is a 2 K by 2
K ray it's a 2048 by 2048 as they are
the the competitive cameras one last
slide on on the BSI another really
interesting advantage that we've we've
developed with these cameras is that
there is a common the existing cameras
experience and you look at a hundred
frame average you can see this fixed
pattern voice fairly clearly in the
image so you see the striations to the
image on the left
on the the prime95 we intentionally
overexposed here so this is very
intentionally overexposed neuron we
weren't actually believing this when we
first saw either that that there just
wasn't this fixed pattern noise as part
of the part of the sensor so it's
remarkably clean it's almost CCD like
and it's background quality and it
surrogates it's just a beautiful
beautiful imaging device okay a fixed
pattern voice so so the idea of better
answers faster there's only fun stuff to
talk about
hopefully convinced you now about the
advantage of 95% QE and it's extremely
high sensitivity in the sensors there's
there's obvious advantage to raw imaging
horsepower but in giving getting to the
better answers faster what does that
give you from an OEM partner what is
this what is why is this compelling
enough to think about redesigning your
instrument or including us in your your
next-generation instrument so as you
have this high QE you get you can use
shorter exposure times and increase your
throughput the shorter exposure times
also means healthier cells so you're
you're less photo bleaching and less
photo toxicity and if you have a higher
throughput and instrument with healthier
cells this is innovative for for our
partners this is compelling this is an
instrument that's that has something
that the competitive instruments myths
cannot so you look at something like a
high throughput screening application
and it demonstrated here they're
screening potential drug compounds and
they're using imaging they're using cell
morphology and screening wells against
potential drug compounds I think it was
a lab roots webinar I I listened to one
day and they said there were 60 billion
unscreened drug compounds kind of
mind-boggling
so this world of screening is a very
important industrial application and so
as you can do this more quickly and with
healthier cells this is this is good for
our
iPod content as we put screening
partners we're going to take a detour
it's the world computational imaging and
so it's a good time to introduce that
what that means to us computational
imaging is a big broad term that's a
little bit a little bit fuzzy right now
it's a it's it's it can mean a lot of
things to different people what it means
for us is that it gives you a space the
computational imaging space is a is
something that we can provide our own
partners that allows you to deploy IP to
create some to add some secret sauce to
your instruments and help differentiate
our partners instruments from their
competitors so it's interesting as I
can't as a camera company it's funny to
say but we care less and less about
images about about pretty pictures
aren't our scientific groups I should
say our scientific group takes beautiful
images and pretty pictures on the OEM
side we're all about getting two answers
we were interested in creating
actionable data in helping your
instrument spit out answers faster so
it's not always about images and expects
us to say that as a camera company but
it's it's out in the world as well and
though if you look at the broader tech
world and medical industries you'll see
that this you know what's attacking out
there in the world is that real-time
data processing is driving decisions you
look at the sensors that are carving
self-driving cars they're not about
streaming images or taking movies or
documenting they're not actionable data
and and helping you not hit the the car
in front of you or help your robot drive
or not hit the car in front of it so
it's it's a different world and it's
something that we're really committed to
pushing on the scientific
instrumentation thought is is helping to
to drive that data processing driving
decisions getting answers and that's
sort of our tagline of better answers
faster this is a big part of that to
illustrate that just to back up into my
as Barry mentioned I'm a biomedical
scientists and
not a an FPGA engineer all the times I
wish I was but to back up into a more
sort of more biological analogy to that
would tell you quickly about
chemotherapy so traditional chemotherapy
cancer is cells growing out of control
such as cancer tumors are our cell
division gone gone wrong and some agents
that inhibit mitosis that prevent cell
division are potent anti-cancer agents
one of the best best of them being the
taxane family of drugs the taxall was
isolated from the Pacific yew tree if
you want your bit of useless trivia for
the for the morning so taxanes are
really powerful what they do is they
bind to these tubulin subunits of
microtubules and they prevent the
microtubule they inhibit its assembly
and disassembly what this means on a
pragmatic place is that it's a stop cell
division cold you need languor tubules
to pull the chromosomes apart from the
metaphase plate to go through cell
division and so if you stop that if you
inhibit those microtubules you stop cell
division and you you shut down cancer
very nicely now something like the
taxall it's a it's a it's a very potent
mitotic inhibitor but there's nothing
specific about it just inhibits mitosis
everywhere and so as you take this for a
chemotherapy agent what you're relying
on is that the tumor cells are dividing
faster than the bulk body cells and so
you you're taking a general anti mitotic
agent that's going to kill all cells but
the reason it works is because it kills
the same two cancer cells faster that
kills the normal somatic cells in your
body this is why chemotherapy agents
also have a side effect of being tough
on your hair to your stomach because
those are naturally more mitotic so so
where am I going with this Sousa broad
agents this is the the old way the
traditional way a more modern way to do
this and what's happening in the medical
world is targeted chemotherapy so
drug called urban tax which is a monocle
and antibodies shown here that's a toxin
AB is its proper name so it's a it's a
monoclonal antibody against the EGF
receptor and it's the EGFR receptor
inhibitor and so this is chemotherapy
agent is coupled to them to the
monoclonal antibody very specifically
shuts down it one particular cellular
pathway involved in cancer followed you
in this case specific to to colon cancer
and certain other very specific forms of
cancer so they're looking at a more
personalized approach to medicine and a
more modern way to do this is it's sort
of the the horse for course there's a
major that does a job and so this is a
better way to go you eliminate some of
the systemic side effects you have a
very targeted approach to to fighting
something so back to camp
thanks cameras the analogy I'm trying to
draw here is that we want to do the same
thing with cameras we want to encourage
a targeted use of cameras and we want to
encourage our our way partners to work
collaboratively with us to select the
right camera for a given application so
we always look at price I mean price is
an important important bit we're always
interested in getting our partners the
right camera for for what their budget
is that performance that you know what
is it that our OEM partners you look at
is if they need that high qED's they
need to frame rate is it a field of view
that's important you know how many
pixels do they need per data point
they're trying to take which relates to
pixel size so the price performance
balance excuse me isn't it's extremely
important for us you know finding that
right point on the price performance
spectrum is is where we start thinking
about the targeted use of cameras in the
OEM setting we look at the mechanical
size and what we can help customize
there and and make sure it fits in your
in your mechanical design or help you
design around the camera and then the
computational imaging bits so we've
created some what we call off-the-shelf
algorithms and then what
really most important your most
interesting to us is this idea of the
custom algorithms in the first bit of
the seminar you know we'll try to
convince you that the cameras are at
ridiculous good performance levels the
cueing and read modes and frame rates
are are nearly perfect there's there's
not a lot of room to improve on a 95 %
QE sensor but we have committed to our
technological leadership position by
focusing on this computational imaging
piece by recommending resources to to
develop this both in the harbor and
software world and and this is where we
have planted our flag pretty solidly in
this computational imaging world
computational imaging for us is this
idea of getting to the better answers
faster and not just images so let's talk
about this what does computational
imaging mean to us it's uh they can mean
a lot of things now our general workflow
is that you know we have algorithms
we've developed I'll show you the noise
and I'll show you spot finding we do
image correction we can do an EDR
routine we can extend that integrated
within the camera so we've developed a
bunch of things internally that we think
are interesting we work with people that
just want access to this this bit too if
we've had discussions with people we
start going into this next thing you
know I'm an FHA engineer I'll get it
then let me add it and that's great you
know we can help we can help you get
into that fga space if you know how to
do that and want to do that on your own
more commonly this is a pretty
collaborative process we work with our
OEM partners to find the computational
routines that are interesting or unique
to help you deploy a bit of that secret
sauce whatever that may be
and that may be starting with C code
that may be starting with something
that's in the realm of C code that you
want you want to execute and within the
camera so it goes anywhere along that
that spectrum for us or if we're
comfortable working that so like to show
you some examples on computational
imaging to get out of the abstract and
into a bit more concrete I'll show you
some of the things that we've done that
that are our
that our meet and we'll hopefully all
this is illustrative of what you can do
with computational imaging it may be
relevant directly for your application
but more likely or hopefully it sort of
sparked something that you think of oh
we could we do that first ones called
denoising so it's more properly it's an
active noise reduction algorithm so it's
a quantitative algorithm but prettier
preserves the raw intensity of the image
data as a mock with the data but it
drops the increase increased adjustable
the noise by about three to five times
by reducing the noise floor that's what
this looks like if you look at a
particular image same camera round same
exposure time same everything if you the
only difference between them is on the
left and then is on the right is this
application of the math is we turn on
the math engine and you can see what
that does to the the profile of the line
profile you get this this nice reduction
in the noise you get finding the yellow
of the yellow line and superpose you can
see the signal doesn't change the signal
intensity remains the same but by
dropping that noise floor out you get a
nice improvement in the image quality
Dean always works really well for
structural features I should have
mentioned it's a moving patch based
algorithm so the way the noising works
is it scans the image and in two or
three passes and increasing patch size
and it looks for areas of structural
similarity that says this is probably an
accent filament or this is probably not
and uses that to subtract out the noise
so it works really well for structural
things but what about something more low
mag as we as we talk with some more part
about this they say well how about you
know field of cells but what would I do
for that works rather nicely so for low
mag cells you can see 3d noising on the
left and and posting moving on right if
it works rather nicely you didn't buy
some provement and in the background and
the image quality
another one we taught it to do particle
tracking so we took the FPGA
and again a couple slides too late but I
better let the number FPGAs are
essential in camera so FPGA is necessary
to run the sensor FPGA is control to
pixel
they control the timing of the sensor
and so you need an FPGA in the camera to
pipe the data through what we do is we
over muscle that we've put about 20
times the FPGA we need just to drive the
sensor and that gives us FPGA is our
excellent computational engines and so
this gives us Headroom is executing but
that's like particle tracking so that be
on the camera here the pga is detecting
the particles and then tracking them
pretty cool algorithm here actually
pretty pretty smart algorithm because
the particle copies the move around X Y
but if it dips in Z the algorithm then
has to go through a predictive analysis
of how many frames it can take could
reappear on along the projected
predicted trajectory try saying that
along the predicted trajectory need to
to assign the same track to continue to
track or to begin a new one so a pretty
smart little algorithm here that's
running entirely within the camera head
on the FPGA you can generate things like
this you can see plots and you can see
directional analysis you can analyze
your articles we felt an algorithm for
super resolution that just very simply
transfers only the molecules of interest
out of each frame over to the host so
it's a big a huge data solution here
some of these super resolution
applications can generate 20,000 frames
of data pretty quickly and chew up hard
drives like they're going out of style
so you really reduce the data size of a
particular set from 160 games to four
gigs which is a nice feature all
entirely within the FPGA so better
answers faster what does mean to us you
know 95% TV cameras though that gets you
better answers faster we've got those
we've got this computational imaging
piece that helps you get better answers
faster and the last bit we mentioned was
was large field of view cameras so when
you meet a large field of view to damage
we've you've found a family of cameras
called iris that exists as a 9 and 15
megapixel camera seem out our f-mount
available here is a board level camera
as well
designed for our OEM partners and it's a
DIY cooling that you have some to save
some some cost it's in space and in the
board level camera and the simple
message here is we have giant sensors
they're big few of you and more samples
per image means faster and faster
answers if you're doing tiling or taking
multiple frames of a sample less frames
means means faster answers as a very
small pixel size and as a for a quarter
micron pixel which is which is nice you
get a lot of pixels per per spot if
you're looking at or your data point and
there are my small form-factor so
designed for this design out of our OEM
group to to make our partners
integration easy 5k by 3k of that
forward order micron pixels so it's a 25
millimeter diagonal big field of view
really really nice nice camera
the iris feature is a very broad cube
profile so fairly unique as you go out
into the red it holds up to about 25 28
% QE at 900 nanometers which is really
excellent some of the competitive
cameras are proud of seven or eight
percent at nine hundred so nice broad to
be profile across the visible and often
to the red and as we look at something
like the iris one particular application
of interest is something like a micro
array multiplex to me the last days so
what that looks like is something like
this go these wells and you have you put
samples across across all the wells you
end up with your data that comes up and
you have each well as a replicate
printing of your your antibodies your
day to look something like this you
might have this PC answer Mahorn react
with a BNC an experiment - we have 50
and so on and so you get data that looks
like this
so computational imaging how might we
apply how computational imaging to help
with a job like this we taught the
camera to find the spots so one of the
cornerstone
you know that there's some of the
current instrumentation it actually has
the you
reacts with the data and come in and
place this great around the data and
they have to tilt it and expand it and
get it just so to analyze the data and
how I might do this is maybe different
than how my lab mate might do this and
so there's a whole look I have here on
my desk that talks about the
delightfulness of my image to take that
analysis so we shortcutted that we
taught the camera to to find the spots
for the application so one step closer
to an answer you don't have to ask the
user to interact with the data and the
camera goes in and finds the spots you
get a nice little GUI that lets you tune
and tweak you and decide on on the spot
size of interest if you wanted to
exclude the little bits of background
the spurious fluorescence here that
that's kind of shown in the background
and only pick up the spots and so we
were successful in teaching the FPGA to
do that and then report that spot
location to the host application and can
also get into some data analysis bits
via some mark helper libraries to
actually then get even closer to answers
so on the iris camera we micro arrays
are pretty easy but it's try cells with
that one and this is the fun part about
all this and again the goal in
presenting all this bit about
computational imaging is it's just an
illustration of interesting things for
us and hopefully sparking something
interesting views you talk about micro
arrays and of course the first partner
revisit said that's neat how about cells
as dolls that's not Spock does it work
sure for the most part you know you even
need it's a circle filter see a defined
spots but we were pretty successful in
an attempt so far at using this to find
and identify cells in the field of view
we worked with no in partner to validate
this thoats as we start talking about
and we these things are cool and neat
and fun to talk about but we wanted to
validate this this data so we looked at
our spot finder with a really kind a we
and collaborators and they ran they had
an in-house algorithm so that we looked
at their data via the spot finder and
then they ran a
watershed algorithm to identify their
own internal mechanism of identifying
the spots and it matched up very very
nicely so it was validated that the the
spot finder algorithm works works well
compared to a classical watershed
algorithm that they hadn't been
employing to find spots
okay spots and cells micro flexor pools
we worked with a group that had droplets
in a field and we're able to go in and
have spot finder find those the goal of
computational imaging is to get closer
to answers and we want that actionable
data the whole tantalizing part of this
is that any of the what we want to see
the cameras and the imaging engines
become a heart of our Parker's
instruments and really help deliver
better data and get to actionable data
that that helps them drive their
expectation
we're very collaborative in this we have
an entire OEM division very focused on
collaboration with our partners and
creating that that balance of what you
need you know we've got the low-light
imaging the low-light cameras with a 95%
QE very innovative and useful for four
instruments that need to dig in the dirt
that need that low level for essence or
low level detection capabilities so we
have the prime family the 95 beans and
the PSI for those low-light high-speed
applications we have the large field of
view massive covered with the iris
family big big 25 millimeter field of
view form 4 micron pixels nice balanced
camera for our OEM applications we've
got this bit of computational imaging we
are absolutely committed to this we are
working on this now we're working on
what's next we have some extremely cool
things in our pipeline that really
excited for for next year's webinar as
well to talk to talk more about this and
some of the things that we've got
cooking on this so we encourage you you
know if this is interesting if this
tickles something of us talk we've going
to end
is sooner rather than later with our
partners and and would love to figure
out what computational imaging looks
like and how it helps your instrument
get better we do customization you know
we can do unique on that way inside
because we can customize cameras as
needed and really our goal is to is to
get to better answers faster and last I
will say at the promise it's it's but
it's a it's a good place to be for us
it's a nice and it's our goal is to help
our partners improve you know their
instruments and win their markets we
want to help our OEM folks win
applications they're chasing and we
believe this is really a strong set of
tools with which to do that so with that
I appreciate you joining thank you for
its elaborate spur for hosting and for
the great platform here with which to
present thank you all for your time and
listening hopefully that made sense and
didn't go too fast you're three bits but
yeah Judy I'm ready for some some
questions thank you Steve for your
presentation a quick reminder for our
audience on how to submit questions
simply type them into the drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window labeled ask a
question and click on the send button
people answer as many questions as time
permits the first question is FPGA based
computational imaging sounds very
interesting I'm not sure what an FPGA is
therefore wouldn't know where to start
where would I even begin that's a lot
good that's a excellent question thank
you for thank you for that and right I
think in the excitement I may have
neglected to even say what did one of
that PJ is I sort of got to it later
it's it's but it's called a field
programmable gate array and it's a it's
a processor chip that exhibited it can
exist in all cameras and as necessary in
cameras to control the camera but by by
over muscling it we give it this
Headroom to perform
these computations it's very good at
doing that it's an excellent little math
engine so it's and having the access to
the data as the data is coming from the
sensor through the FPGA anyway off to
the host it gives us a really nice
platform to deploy some of this
computation now I yeah a really good
question where do I start the week it's
the slime again keep in mind I'm a
biologist as well so this is uh this is
very dear to my heart about how you how
to use this how do you make this this is
relevant for my application it starts
just from the way in partnership it
starts as just an idea do you have
something that you'd like to do that
would help you get to an answer faster
as they're processing you're doing are
you using only regions of image are you
is there a map that you're applying on
your host machine that we might be able
to bring into the camera to reduce the
the CPU dependence on the host side I
mentioned that we've worked with the
holes you know we've run the entire
range excuse me of people with
partnerships in this and there's people
that say this is super cool you know
I've no idea this the first time I heard
of that PGA I don't know how I would
access it but I have some code that
we're doing in our host machine what
would that look like in an FPGA
environment so we could evaluate that
with you we'll look at the code we found
that we've received C code from partners
that um that we analyze and walk through
and see what it looks like deployed in
FPGA States will also work with people
that like I said word you know that's
this point they say you know I've spent
my life working an FPGA let me add it
and so we can kind of help hack into
that with partners that are ready for
that piece as well if you want to you
know if you have a VGA Topps internally
we can if we can help you to access that
so I think was that those I get the
question Judy was that was that yes that
was great thank you okay here's your
next one what's next for scientific
cameras with 95 percent QE and lo read
noise how much better will they get yes
right so tricky one right tough question
how much better will they get
ninety ninety-five percent is very close
to a hundred III did you know there's
material if the other there's we starts
a bond up gives delivered to the laws of
physics of those pesky pesky laws of
physics so I you know how much will they
get better than 95 maybe you know there
may be another percent or two or three
to improve them there but you know
there's still improvements agreed noise
the cameras the cameras of you know
we're never done innovating on the
hardware side eaters there's always
improvements to the noise floor the
frame rate and a data transfer we've got
a bunch of things we're working on on
the hardware side as well
however we are what's next in our
opinion is really the embracing of
computational imaging in the scientific
world I sort of mentioned it in passing
but it's it's happening in the world
around us they are flying drones around
in warehouses not to image the the
inventory but to report back to an
operator that there's a problem in Aisle
seven that's the kind of idea of
actionable data that we see coming from
computational imaging and so that's
where we see the future going that's
what we believe is next and we are
trying our best to to push this into the
sciences and and are absolutely
committed to this as a platform for the
scientific imaging and for our alien
partners there's you know artificial
intelligence algorithms that can be
developed and deployed through these
sort of methods there's you know big
data sets that can be analyzed and
pattern matching things there's there's
a whole world of things it's you know
really I'd say it's surprisingly ahead
of the scientific imaging world in the
broader tech world in a module world and
what they're doing with drones and cars
and medical procedures these days is
staggering so in the biomedical sciences
this is coming this is all going to
happen and and
we are positioning ourselves to tell our
partners get there looks like we have
time for one more question
you didn't mention CCD cameras in the
presentation I've heard they aren't
being manufactured anymore
is this correct good yes thank you thank
you for that question as well I passed
through them a bit there was a bit of
mention a CCD of early on and it was
sort of certainly there in near and dear
technology to our company as they've
made our cooking our company with what
we were founded on as an astronomy
company in CCDs
but I'm glad to get this chance to
mention this because there's a lot of
information and you know it some some
good some bad flying around about CCDs
we still have CCD cameras we see CDs or
a dynamite camera we still have six CDs
and production CCD cameras are available
so so the the questions alluding to the
fact that Sony has announced they're
shutting down their CCD fab so as the
world has gone the CMOS you know the big
volume applications are all in CMOS
these days so so Sony who ruled the CCD
landscape for a long time with the icx
family of cameras of sensors has
announced the there has closed that back
down they've built up a massive amount
of stock and they've asked us all for
forecast and we have a guaranteed supply
line on CCD cameras through about 2023
or there abouts so we have a you know
that the end is in sight it's not an
immediate CCD apocalypse but but yes but
this is correct your question is correct
that the CCDs
have announced the the fabs have
announced the sunsetting of CCDs and
just makes it all that much more
interesting all the CMOS bits we're
talking about so we're working with our
partners if you're on a CCD platform now
and are ready to start thinking about
that bit was next it's a great time to
have that discussion you've got some
time and your current product lines to
enjoy CCPs and they are great but we're
confident that we can help you help our
partners fine
CMOS alternative that will we'll fill
that next generation instrument I would
like to once again thank
Steve Smith for his presentation do you
have any final comments yeah
this is really fun this is Tom this is a
really neat place to be working in and
this is a very fun discussion we have
with our partners and figuring out what
this looks like in and what they're
currently doing and what they might be
able to do so I just really encourage
I'm I think you are our emails are
available through lab roots and any
questions we didn't get to I think I'll
have access to and I promise to respond
to everybody that that's asked to
questions so thank you for the questions
if there's others I'd love to get that
for you love to have this discussion
with you
you know lab remove you can find our out
of contact us through lab routes and
this is a really fun time to be in
scientific imaging so I'm really
grateful for the chance to be able to
share this with you all face of thank
you again see but I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions and as Steve
said questions we did not have time for
today will be addressed by the speaker
you the contact information you provided
at the time of registration we would
like to thank our sponsor photo metrics
for underwriting today's educational
webcast this webcast can be viewed
on-demand through august 2018 lab routes
will alert you via email when it's
available for replay and we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed a live
event until next time goodbye